[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
um can you hear me yes we can hear you
yes
excellent thank you yes the commission
yesterday launched
some interesting projects in the areas
of cultural heritage and digital
digital education first a competence
center which aims at preserving and
protecting european cultural heritage
the center has been granted up to three
million euros from horizon in 2020
it will enable access to data meter data
and guidelines
bringing together expertise from various
academic disciplines in the area
of cultural heritage and cultural
heritage preservation
second we also launched two projects to
support digital education
world up to 1 million euros each also
through horizon in 2020
one is a mentoring project that aims to
mobilize
120 schools in six member states
belgium czechia croatia italy hungary
and portugal
as well as the uk to advance digital
innovation in particular
in small or rural schools and for
socially disadvantaged
students and the other projects will
allow for the creation of regional
regional innovation hubs and also
mentoring
this involves 600 teachers in 75 schools
in estonia finland italy and lithuania
but also georgia norway norway and the
uk and as always you'll find more
information
in the daily news thank you thank you
very much
johannes this brings us to the end of
our announcement
and we will now therefore take your
questions i passed the floor
to atanasius atlas welcome back
to all happy new year
uh i got a simple question
that has to do with all that we've been
hearing
in the last couple of weeks is the
president happy
with the vaccination strategy
so far and i mean the implementation
part in the vaccine acquisition part
as well because you know there is a lot
of complaining we are too slow we are
too fast
we get too much we got too little all
that stuff how do you answer
to all that stuff to all those
complaints and
uh what's the opinion of the president
on the whole
operation so far thanks
thank you very much atanacios um well
as you know the uh the commission
has very very early on um
understood that both the acquisition
of vaccines and the vaccination process
would mean major endeavors for the
european union
and that it was key that the european
union
act in a cohesive
manner in this respect because
we are a united continent we have
freedom of movement
of people of goods etc and therefore
it is extremely important that we have a
vaccine vaccination strategy that
encompasses the whole of the european
union
we've had many many opportunities here
in the press room to describe to you
how the process was moving forward and
indeed
continues to move forward the president
in a press conference just before the
g20 summit last autumn
explained to you what the state of play
was on the vaccination process
and how we were looking forward to the
process
being rolled out as the new year begins
so we are obviously very much focused on
ensuring
that the implementation of our strategy
is done is done well and that all the
actors including obviously
the member states play their part in
this so quite frankly
it's still early days as you know we
have signed a certain number of
contracts we've signed six contracts we
have
approval of one and hopefully very soon
approval of a second vaccine and further
vaccines
later on and of course the coming weeks
and months will be very important
in terms of the rollout of of this
vaccination
so we are very very focused on making
sure that it works well
it's obvious that such a complex
endeavor is always going to bring with
it
um difficulties that will always be
bumps on the road but we are confident
that with all the efforts that we have
put in
we will be able to ensure vaccination
of europeans as quickly as possible
are there other questions for us on
this issue today please only keep your
hand raised
if it is on this um on this issue
i see many hounds raised
please only keep your hand raised if it
is on vaccination or vaccines
i let you a bit of time
and i see that epp has a
question
hello uh do you hear me yes we hear you
go ahead
yes happy new year and thank you for
the question i i have two questions
one is about activities
the commission is doing at the moment
for example to fasten
somehow uh the amounts of
vaccines coming to the states other
something going
on some kind of negotiations to have
bigger amounts or maybe
um negotiations to to have like bigger
production facilities or doing something
and another question about this
critics about being too slow
do you agree that um commission and
european union was
too slow uh and uh
too a little ambitious
uh concerning for example uh the deal
with praiser and biotech
thank you very much i will pass the
floor to stefan
thank you very much first i i hope you
can hear me
yes go ahead okay and also from my side
especially a healthy
2021. um two questions
um first on what is the commission doing
or what are we doing with regards to
uh discussions on on the deliveries of
those and so on
um i think one of the
one of the main bottlenecks that we are
all experiencing now is the the
production capacity of course this is a
very
important bottleneck that we are all
facing ourselves
and the commission is of course in
contact with the different uh
with the different producers with the
member states to see how
things can be improved i would like to
draw your attention also to the fact
that part of the contracts that have
been concluded
with these companies foresee in actual
support
by the commission to develop this
production capacity
your second question is has to do with
worry too slow
and have we and secondly have we not
ordered not enough doses
let me start with the second part the
european union has
managed to develop a very diversified
portfolio
of almost 2 billion doses
you have to know that this portfolio has
been developed on a time
of big uncertainty when we were
negotiating these contracts with these
six companies
and also with other companies when we
were negotiating these there was no
certainty whatsoever that
any of these vaccines would be
considered safe and effective
by the european medicine agency so we
were acting in the context of an
important uncertainty
in order to cover this the main
philosophy of the strategy
was to develop a diversified portfolio
investing and and reserving doses from
different companies using different
technologies
thereby increasing the chance that at
least one or even more of these vaccines
would be considered safe and effective
at a later stage and that's exactly what
we've done
and we've developed a very wide and
diversified portfolio
exactly to do this we don't put all our
eggs in one basket
but we want to increase our chances and
that's what
we've been doing that in a context of
uncertainty from the beginning
um your other question were we too
worried too late i would say rather in
the country the the eu vaccine strategy
was already adopted and
approved and endorsed at the highest
level by the heads of state in
june again working in in on a moment
that there was no certainty about any of
these
vaccine um developments i would like to
draw your attention also to the fact
that for instance when it comes to
buying tech pfizer
we had already introduced or invested in
in this company well before it became
clear
that the vaccine that was developed by
the company would
be successful so we have been from the
beginning been very open
to develop a portfolio which is as broad
as possible
investing in companies to make sure that
we have this
production capacity thank you
thank you i moved to yanis
hello there can you hear me yeah go
ahead janice
happy new year to everyone um also on
the vaccine i want to ask
is there a frustration in the commission
about the fact that
ema seems to be taking a lot longer with
the
astrazeneca vaccine than than other
regulatory authorities
we've heard that it's unlikely that it
will be approved in
within january is there frustration that
some member states
have not done the necessary preparatory
work for the rollout and
thus you know days have gone by and have
they vaccinated very few people and
could the commission have done something
more to help
to help them along in that and is there
has a discussion begun with ecdc
or ema as as it has in other countries
about
possibly moving to a one dose regiment
or pushing the second dose a lot further
into the future
so as to get more people uh vaccinated
in the early stages
thank you thank you janice many
questions there i pass the floor back to
stefan
thank you very much janice i will go
backwards in my questions the first the
last question that you asked i will take
first
are the discussions on using one of
those or two those and so on this is a
medical question that i believe is best
to be
raised with colleagues from the european
medicine agency the question whether it
would make sense indeed
to go from two doses or to one dose this
obviously has medical implications and
i think it makes sense to contact the
colleagues of
emma as far as
the vaccination campaigns are concerned
where are we with the vaccination
campaigns are we frustrated or not
frustrated i would say that frustration
is probably not
a word in in our vocabulary here
i would like to draw your attention to
the fact that the commission already in
mid-october
announced recommendations or adopted
recommendations to help member states
with the preparation of the vaccination
it contained very
practical recommendations on for
instance identifying and time the
priority groups
on making sure the infrastructure is
ready i'll make sure there's sufficient
resources and so on and this has been
followed by member states we are talking
with member states about it the ecdc has
made
a first assessment of the situation
already a few weeks ago and he's
continuing to follow this
let us not forget that this is an
extremely complex
process this is a pandemic we have never
ever seen
in in the history of the european union
so this is a very
important complex undertaking and
we are in contact with the member states
to make sure
that this this vaccination is very
complex
uh campaigns can take place as well as
possible
as far as the recognition or rather the
authorization of the astrazeneca vaccine
is concerned
and whether there is any frustration
with regard to aim there is of course no
frustration with regard to emma
we have always said that it is
fundamental that the vaccines that are
distributed to our european citizens are
safe
and effective and secondly that we can
convince
our european citizens of the importance
of having this vaccination
and this is why member states and the
commission
are all of the opinion that is very
important that
the vaccines are assessed by the
european medicine agency an independent
agency of
scientists who are extremely well placed
to assess effectiveness
and quality and this is exactly what
emma is doing
ema has sped up its processes for
instance
by applying rolling reviews rolling
reviews basically means that before
companies
introduce a request for vaccination or
vaccine authorization
that they can already before that stage
submit
data which may become available this
allows emma to already assess
these data before the official
submission of a market authorization
request
and it helps ema do a much faster job as
soon as
the request
is introduced by the company of course
the important step that has to be taken
as well
is that the company has to submit a
um a market authorization request and in
that context i refer as far as
astrazeneca is concerned
to a press release that this has been
published by emma
a few days ago in which they explained
the state of play of this file
and the additional information that they
have requested from this company
thank you thank you
i see many hands raised so let us try to
be concise
david
we
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
hi eric happy new year no it's not on
the back side okay then
hold your fire please we'll come back to
you afterwards
are there other questions on vaccines
frederick i know your question is on
something else
nice your question on vaccines
please only keep your hand raised if
your question is on vaccines
push the you know re-push the button to
unraise your hand if it's not a question
on vaccines
okay i see some hands have some hands
disappeared very nice
hi and happy new year for me as well
thank you for the question
um i just wanted to get back um to what
what stefan said in the beginning
because the biontech
contract was actually concluded on i
think in november 11th
in any case at a point where it was
clear that it
was both effective and safe
and um it has been suggested by biontech
that you could have bought more at that
point
and the question is is that true
did you forego the chance to to order
more at that point and
why thank you thank you
stephan
hi um i'm not sure this is entirely
correct
um it is true that you know when we
start our negotiations
for most companies clinical trials had
not yet started
and for those companies for for which
the vaccine trials had started we did
not have final results
yet so it's very important we to
acknowledge
that we worked in an environment of
scientific uncertainty i would say i
would also like to draw the attention to
the fact that
for us the main criterion to go ahead
with a vaccine is
the green light from the european
medicine agency these are the scientists
who
whose role is to really assess and check
thoroughly the safety and the
effectiveness of the vaccine when this
independent agency gives the green light
the commission can then go ahead with
its authorization
so um i would not agree with the fact
that there was already certainty
um before this stage we wait for the
scientific approach of
emma which has always been considered as
a very important step
by the commission and by the member
states not just to ensure the safety but
also to
show to the european citizens that the
vaccinations that they are taking are
safe
thank you thank you
hans
yes thank you hans von burkhead from
politico happy new year to you all
um stefan just to follow up on what you
said on the diversification of the
portfolio i get your argument that
you're saying it's good to put
the eggs in different baskets however
wouldn't have
wouldn't it have been wiser to put just
have
more eggs at the disposal and put more
eggs in the different baskets because
for the modern vaccination vaccine for
example we will only have 160 million i
think that is going to be approved
hopefully in the coming days so
in in general uh considering the high
economic costs of
continued lockdowns wouldn't it have
been wiser just to
buy more of all these vaccines to have
more at the disposal
when we actually find out which ones
work and
what was the problem there was it member
states not um
handing out enough money or why didn't
we just in general
buy more of all vaccines in a
diversified
approach as you described it thank you
before passing the floor to hans
uh to to stefan hanse let me remind you
that we have actually signed contracts
that would allow member states
to get access to 2 billion doses
so largely enough to
to vaccinate the whole of the european
uh population so the issue
is not really one of the number of doses
it is one of the the production capacity
and this is an issue which everybody is
um is
facing that faster floor to stefan if he
has further details
um i think what you said was indeed very
important here i can only say again that
we want to invest in different companies
using different technologies and i would
like to stress also the fact that what
i've already done before that we were
working
in a context of uncertainty up to as
late as
end october there were still certain
scientific experts who were skeptical on
our
rna vaccines so we are working in such
an environment of
uncertainty and again to spread this we
had to spread the risk or rather to
increase the chances to have
successful vaccines we felt it important
to have
these different eggs in our basket
which as eric said has led up to a
reservation of almost
2 billion doses which is quite an
important amount especially if these
vaccines
would be considered all these vaccines
would be considered safe
and effective thank you let me remind
you that this negotiation was done
by the commission with the member states
taking into account of course also the
wishes of member states uh
and uh their understanding of the
advantages and different disadvantages
of different um of different
technologies of different
contracts etc so um you know the
the exact scope of each of the contract
is something that takes into account
the balance of all these uh
characteristics that have been put
forward
and described by stefan
okay um louise
louise you have a question vaccines yeah
yeah can you hear me yes go ahead yeah
perfect thanks now i was just wondering
in the contract with the
with the companies is there not any kind
of clause or anything that
they actually have to um maybe not split
their patent on the on the
on the the active doe and active matter
but
maybe licensed in other vaccine
facilities so you can actually so they
could actually you know
step up the the vaccination doses made
or is there any kind of pressure from
the commission for them to sort of
you know yeah get the the production
done faster
by using other companies maybe
thank you i think it's um it's it's a
very tricky question
to actually outsource the production of
a vaccine
to different uh production facilities
you know these are not fruit juices that
you bottle
from and with all respect to the
producers of fruit juices because
we want them fresh and we want them
obviously to be very tasty so it's not
easy either but when you're talking
about
very sophisticated vaccines you just
don't
don't shift production from one capacity
to another and of course we are working
with the producers in order to um
to help them increase production
capacity and as a matter of fact
as stefan said it in his first
intervention if i remember well
we were actually one of the first to
invest for example
in bayern tech or for example in curvak
as
the german government did in order to
to increase production and capacity
jillian
my question happy new year um i have two
good questions about the
vaccines of course um biotech said that
that um the eu will get 12.5 million
doses by the end of 2020.
i was wondering if that if they made
good on that um
promise um i was also wondering it's a
bit of a blame game going on right now
between member states and the commission
of you know whose fault
or these members saying some germany are
saying that but it was the commission
for not um
purchasing enough of these biointegras
or vaccines but i'm also curious and
france has been very delayed and rolling
out these vaccines the netherlands is
just beginning today
i mean i'm curious if you have any
comment on that do you do you feel like
one of the big issues here is that
european countries did not prepare
enough
to vaccinate thank you stephan
thank you very much as far as the exact
number is concerned that has been
delivered to the different
member states i don't have the different
uh exact numbers per member state
you may wish also to to contact the
colleagues from uh from the company to
see what has been lived at exactly what
moment in time to the member states as
far as the vaccination uh
the vaccination campaigns are concerned
in the member states i can only say that
refer to what i said before that already
mid october we have adopted
recommendations helping member states to
prepare themselves
for the uh vaccination campaigns this is
a topic which is discussed between the
member states for instance in the
context
of the health security committee and
where member states
discuss with each other the state of
play how to take things forward
and so on i would also like to stress
that as i said before
this is a very huge complex
undertaking this is not easy and so this
requires a lot of
good preparation we are not here to see
who did well or
who did not well we are all together in
this boat
we want to make sure that the whole
european union gets out of this pandemic
as quickly as possible
following good vaccination campaigns
and the commission stands ready as you
also know to support member states
wherever they feel the commission
support may be useful
thank you okay thank you
i'm um i'm going to pass the phone now
to michael
michael peel you had a question i know
that question i know
i i do uh yes
i wanted to follow up on hans's question
which i feel wasn't quite fully answered
one approach would be to perhaps
order a billion doses of every vaccine
and then have an arrangement where this
can then be
um sold on or donated on to other
countries around the world
who who need them um whatever is not uh
is not used in the eu
can you just be explicit about why that
approach was not taken
was it about cost or was it because you
looked at manufacturing schedules
and you realized that it would not be
possible because of those or was it for
some other reason
michael i think we are talking about
purposes the first thing
to say is that the commission did not
buy doses of vaccines
as i said time and time again here in
the press human stefan as well
the commission invested
in different companies we acted as an
investor
in order to provide funding to
pharmaceutical companies that were
developing
vaccines at that point in time in order
to
help them speed up their research the
development
and then their production capacities
it is the member states who then decide
whether they want to buy a specific
vaccine and how many
doses of that vaccine it is not us
that is very important to remember the
second thing is that
as we have as we have said the issue is
not the number of vaccines
the number of vaccines that we have is
sufficient and of course
takes into account european population
and the other commitments
that we have that we have taken but
ultimately these vaccines have to be
produced they have to be
delivered some of the logistical chains
logistics change that are involved can
be very very sophisticated
so member states have to decide
whether they consider that one or more
vaccine is suited
to their needs this is how the process
works so you know we could buy 10
billion vaccines if
um if the member states we can sorry we
could have
signed contracts for purchase by member
states of up to 10 billion vaccines
but if the member states ultimately
don't buy these vaccines
then it serves absolutely no
no purpose so again i don't think that
the issue is really the number of
vaccines
it is the fact that we are at the
beginning of a roll out
uh you know we're all judging this as if
this campaign is over in fact the
campaign
is just starting let me remind you that
um
in the autumn when we were discussing
this we were saying
that the rollout of vaccines would start
at the end of the year
and progressively build up with the big
deliveries of vaccines foreseen
around the month of april so you know
it's quite astonishing in a way
to see that now we are all turning
around and saying why are not all of the
doses of vaccines
already present on the market it has
always been clear
from the beginning that we were
developing a portfolio
with the results of the strategy of
course depending
first and foremost on the assessment
that would be made by emma
based on the clinical trials done by the
by the companies and that progressively
these vaccines would come on the market
this is the phase that we are in now the
first vaccines
are being approved they're going to be
put on the market
the eu is getting the doses that it has
reserved where it has a possibility to
do so it is
exercising the options that it has or
even negotiating
for further for further doses so that
member states
can then decide which ones to deploy in
their population
okay are there other questions on
vaccines patricia you know your question
is on something else
uh frederick as well so i will come to
you later francesco is it a question on
vaccines
yes go ahead good morning and happy new
year um
yeah it's two questions the first is a
follow-up to a question from
my one of my colleagues who was not
answered by stefan
uh it's the question about uh the
commission
having the client that they you were
having declined to buy more doses of the
pfizer biotech vaccine
earlier this year we know from internal
from an internal document that there was
an offer for 500 million doses
back in july uh and
the eu negotiators said uh you know
that offer down because of because of
because of financial reasons uh so
we have never got a unofficial
confirmation for that so it would be
great if
stefan could uh make a comment on that
given that now it's relatively public
and second
uh i have a second question what stefan
said
today he said that the eu
is looking at ways to increase
the number of doses that pfizer biontec
could delete could deliver to the eu
in addition to the 300 million dollars
is already agreed
uh is this in conflict potentially with
what
germany is doing uh we know that germany
is ordering now
new doses of the same vaccine on its own
in breach of at least the spirit of the
eu joint procurement
so now we we may have a situation in
which the eu is competing with germany
to buy uh doses of the same vaccine
so are you discussing this with germany
is there a risk for a potential conflict
and as germany offered you any guarantee
that
the new doses that uh is gonna
is going to acquire from biontech
will be delivered only after the very
last
dose of the 300 million order is going
to be delivered to you state so the way
there is a risk that germany may jump
the queue
thank you thank you very much stephan
thank you very much francesco that's not
two questions that's six questions i
think
first as far as this question is
concerned that
we would have rejected and offered for
more doses
i can only say what i what i have said
before we
do not put all our eggs in one basket
the whole philosophy was
that we want to have sufficient doses
from sufficient number of companies
to increase the chances to develop or to
find rather
a vaccine which is successful and safe
and that has always been at the core at
the heart of the negotiations
with each of these six companies so
that's
that's something that uh explains why we
have followed the path
that we have followed diversification of
our portfolio
as far as these additional doses are
concerned um you know that
um as i said before uh as far as the
biotech physical
vaccine is concerned we had ordered or
reserved rather
200 million doses and then the
commission decided to exercise the
option to
reserve an addition additional up to 100
million doses
discussions are now ongoing as i also
said before between member states and
the commission as to how to
take this additional reservation of 100
million additional doses
forward in terms of distribution between
member states
some member states may wish less other
member states
may wish more we have these discussions
in the context
of this additional doses and therefore
in the context of our
eu vaccines strategy when it comes to
bilateral agreements which would
allegedly have been concluded
by member states with companies i invite
you to contact
the authorities of
of these member states about this what i
only wanted to say
um before when i mentioned to the
additional doses
this is when whenever the commission
considers the importance of
or the possibility of going for
additional doses this obviously always
takes
takes place under the umbrella within
the the context
of the eu vaccine strategy because as we
have
seen before the eu vaccine strategy is
based on
joint work on co-op cooperation which
gives us the best
possible approach to reach good deals
that cover
all the member states thank you
okay thank you very much stefan i'm
going to close the vaccine chapter now
which has been going on for three
quarters of an hour
and i know that there are many other
questions which colleagues would
want to ask so i passed the floor
to patricia
thank you very much eric so
um i would like to know if
the political instability and the risk
of a crisis
in italy concerns the eu commission
more in general and in particular if
this
uh concerns the eu commission in
um in relation to the unfolding of the
recovery fund
and i would also like uh to know if you
have some kind of a timetable
of the ratifications of the own
resources
by the parliaments of the different eu
countries
thank you thank you very much patricia
as you know
we make it a rule not to comment on the
internal political situation
uh in any of our member states and uh
there are good reasons for that so we
will certainly
uh stick to this line we are cooperating
with the italian authorities as we are
with the authorities
of all uh all the member states on all
the political files that
we must master together on the issue
of the timetable for ratification of the
own resources decision i passed the
floor to ballast
hello good afternoon and happy new year
to all of you
now patricia on your specific question i
think it's worth starting this new year
by saying that um
towards the end of the last year a lot
of progress was made in terms of
budgetary matters we have an mff we have
an annual budget
in place as of the beginning of this
year and the next big step as you
correctly are referring to
is the entry into force of the recovery
recovery plan now for that to happen of
course the own resources decision needs
to be
ratified by all member states that's the
very last step to complete but it's a
very
important step now it would be difficult
for me to give you a timeline since
it is up to the member states to decide
when they
when and how they wish to ratify the
amendment of their own
resources decision but i can tell you
and what we've said before
is that we expect this work to be
carried out at the latest by the second
quarter
of this year which would allow us to
kick-start
the recovery plan which is much needed
as you as you know
now for the um exact process that the
ratification of the own resources
decision entails in the member states i
would refer you to the member states
we know that this will involve the
parliaments
the procedure will involve the
parliaments in in many cases but not in
all cases but again for the
specific procedure and timeline the best
would be to turn to the member states
directly
thank you very much patricia you have a
follow-up
go ahead i would like to know uh
where are we in in regard to the
national plans then
is italy uh on time on that is
everything okay
in that respect thank you
thank you um mata is absent so i pass
the floor to ariana on this
on this question if she can provide you
with an update ariana
hi eric hi hi everyone happy new
new year i'm afraid i cannot provide
much of an update
uh what i can say is that we remain an
intensive dialogue
with member states on the preparation of
the national
uh recovery and resilience plans uh but
as i said this is as far as we can go
for the time being
thank you very much okay we switch
files thank you balash and i go to
frederick
we
[Music]
so it's a question about brexit and the
internal
energy market so as of 1 january the uk
is no longer part of the internal
energy market the commission mentioned
um uh that this um
that there was a new market coupling for
seen between the eu
uh and the uk can you give us an
indication of when
this new market coupling will be adopted
will it be this year um
and the commission also sent out a
briefing saying that this new
arrangement will be less efficient
than the market coupling used within the
eu
can you explain in what way it will be
less efficient
than the previous arrangement
thank you i passed the floor to
vivian
hi good afternoon and happy new year to
everyone as well
so indeed as of the 1st of january the
uk is no longer
part of the u's internal energy market
and the energy trades over electricity
interconnectors between the eu and the
great britain will no longer be managed
through the existing single market tools
such as market coupling as they are
reserved for you member states as you
said yourself
i'd like to point out also that
according to the withdrawal
agreement northern ireland will maintain
the single electricity market
with ireland when it comes to now
for the new framework
we have agreed between the european
union and the united kingdom
to establish a new framework for our
future cooperation in the field of
energy
ensuring the efficiency of
[Music]
of cross-border trading and this
new framework would of course be
underpinned by strong provisions in the
agreement aimed at creating our bus
level playing field when it comes to the
timing of it
then of course we are working hard on
making sure that we
make these things happen at the earliest
convenience
what we look at the when we look in
details at the agreement
then it will uh establish also we aim it
to establish also an ambitious
framework for cooperation in the fight
against climate change as well as
provisions for cooperation in the
development of offshore energy
with a clear focus on the north sea and
when it comes to the separate agreement
between europe
and the united kingdom on the safe and
peaceful uses of nuclear energy
uh providing for wide-ranging
cooperation on nuclear safety and
peaceful uses of nuclear energy
this is another part of the work that
we're looking at now
thank you thank you very much
um i see that federic has a follow up
friday
yes thank you vivian you didn't explain
uh why or how the new agreement will be
less efficient
uh than the previous arrangement under
the internal energy market
uh because that is something that the
commission said in the in the q a that
was
uh circulated when the agreement was
struck so
can you give an explanation there and
maybe using
an example um if say there is
a cold snap and the uk
needs to import gas or electricity as a
matter of emergency
will eu countries be obliged to supply
the uk market with energy
or not frederik thank you for your
question we will come back to you
on this um it's a question that should
be addressed by tim
who is uh currently uh on a
well-deserved
um holiday so we will uh we will come
back to you by
with the answer to your uh to your
question
i now move on to other issues and i go
to
nima who had indeed raised her hand
quite early
quite early on nima you have the floor
you need to press speak
we cannot hear you nema
[Music]
[Music]
iranian government the spokesperson says
this morning
they have already begun 20 percent
uranium
enrichment at fordhu facility
um you already repeatedly described the
beginning of the 20 percent enrichment
process as a sign of the
end of maybe this nuclear dj cpua
i'm wondering for peter is the nuclear
deal is
over thank you i passed the floor indeed
to peter on this
thank you i hope i could hear everything
and happy new year of course uh to
everyone
on this um latest announcement of course
we have taken note
of iran's announcement and before
answering your question actually
whether the jcpoa deal is uh at the end
i would say that if this announcement is
going to be implemented the announcement
by the iranian authorities it would
constitute a considerable departure from
iran's nuclear commitments under the
jcpoa
with serious non-nuclear
non-proliferation implications
now let me recall also the importance of
avoiding any steps that could undermine
the preservation of the nuclear deal
and here i would like to recall all the
previous statements by all the
participants of the jcpoa that they are
interested
in keeping this deal alive and the deal
will be kept alive
as long as all the participants deliver
on their obligations
now regarding this announcement so far
the international atomic
energy agency has not confirmed the
practical implementation of the
announcement
and our assessment of iran's nuclear
program is based on
actions that iran has in fact taken
and as they are confirmed by the iaea
i'm saying this knowing that the iaea
has short while ago announced that the
head of the agency will be briefing the
member states later today
um in relation to iran's nuclear program
so we will see what the iaea will say
and as i said the iaea is recognized
independent monitoring and verification
authority
for iran's nuclear program and on its
assessments
we are basing our decisions and our
actions
thank you very much are there other
questions for peter on
foreign relations
redeemed you have a follow-up but quick
please
and also we can hear you very badly go
ahead
and vote
is
[Music]
security council by the end of last
month
the secretary general mr gutierrez
suggested the deployment of the
ceasefire mechanism with the
participation of international observers
so my question is what is the first the
eu reaction to this
suggestion second will the european
union
take part in this observation or
monitoring mechanism and what could be
the scale of the european union
participation
that's my question on libya i have a
question on iran it's the kind of
follow-up
if iran is implementing what
it announced this morning this will be a
double violation
one on enrichment level second the
location where the enrichment level uh
is is going to be which is the
underground
nuclear facility in iran
does that mean that the european union
in case that iran is implementing and
confirmed by the agency
uh the level of the implementation of
the arrangement at 20
that the nuclear deal is finished and
then european union
will move ahead with sanction against
iran
thank you i believe that peter has
already said that we were not going to
go into hypothetical scenarios at this
stage
so he i can i can only
refer you to the answer he gave
previously
to nima on your question on libya peter
indeed nothing to answer regarding iran
on
libya we haven't received of course the
report the report by the u.n secretary
general was for the u.n security council
but the european union has continuously
stressed that we are ready to increase
our support to the un
to keep the ceasefire in libya working
as a precondition for any kind of
political advancement
in the country and to develop a
political dialogue and the hrvp
was very vocal many times that the eu
is offering its full support to the u.n
efforts and to the berlin process
in particular this issue was discussed
in depth at the fac on the 18th of
november
where the hrvp again repeated our
preparedness and readiness to support
the un in any way we can
and we are in contact with our partners
in u.n to see
in what exact way we can show such
support
thank you peter i see that
maria had a question for you on
bosnia maria you have the floor
hello i hope you can hear me yes go
ahead
hey marie absalo with euro news a
question on lipa camp
and eu bosnia relations in general so we
saw
hrvp's announcement on the leap account
and we saw the that the eu allocates
additional
3.5 million to
for the migrants so i would like to ask
what the state of play
with the company situation there if
there is an
anything new from this front and
what about the relationship between the
eu and bosnia zero now what's
if there's any anything new on that
thank you very much
thank you maria peter
thank you maria and indeed the european
union the members of the european
commission
have been very busy over the last few
days regarding the situation
in um lipa camp or bira camp and in
general
conveying the message to uh to the
partners in bosnia-herzegovina that the
situation
in us kosanski canton in the canton una
sana is unacceptable and has to be
solved
immediately we cannot wait i mean this
is a humanitarian
situation uh this humanitarian disaster
could have been prevented if the
authorities would have been acting
as asked already before the christmas
period by the joint statement of three
commissioners
and this is about saving lives of people
so we expect the european union and its
member states are expecting the
authorities in bosnia and herzegovina at
all levels
to take immediate action to solve the
situation
urgently this is about saving lives we
are talking about hundreds of people in
harsh winter conditions
where their health and their lives are
at stake and
the authorities in bosnia herzegovina
have humanitarian obligations
international obligations in this regard
so there have been calls um by various
members of the commission hrvp
urging the authorities to find solution
to provide at the latest stage i mean
the most recent call was to provide
supplies of electricity and water at
lipa camp
and uh it's not only that we are asking
bosnia and herzegovina to do something
we are
doing our own share considerable share
the funding announced yesterday
is only in addition to more than 85
million euros provided since 2018 to
bosnia and herzegovina to deal with the
situation of migrants in the country
and what we are saying also that
long-term solutions are urgently needed
and bosnia and herzegovina and this is
the message and also
answer to your second part to the second
part of your question
bosnian and hetzegovinian authorities
should behave
like authorities in an aspiring eu
country
and people's lives cannot be sacrificed
for internal political power struggles
so the situation needs to be solved
immediately the decisions taken at the
highest federal level in bosnia and
herzegovina need to be implemented
now these decisions about the the camps
and the situation of these people stuck
in harsh winter condition
knee conditions needs to be solved
because all this is negatively affecting
image of bosnian herzegovina in the eyes
of the eu member states but also
on the international stage thank you
peter nicola
nikolai i think you have a question on
the same issue
yes thank you can you hear me yes go
ahead yes
yes i had to follow up on that as well i
mean uh of the 3.5 million euros that
was announced yesterday how much of that
is going to the bosnian state
and you mentioned that the the
additional support is going to
help the refugees and the migrants with
blankets and things like this
so when exactly do you know when will
they be
getting this it will be like today
tomorrow this week
and also maybe on the 88
or 80 more than 85 million the
humanitarian aid that you've given to
bosnia over this
this issue since um early 2018 can you
also give us a breakdown how much
of that went to to the bosnian state as
well um
thank you thank you so much well let's
see what detail we can provide you
on the breakdown of the figures but this
is more question for bala
indeed so the three and a half million
euro is purely humanitarian assistance
what does this mean this means that we
don't
provide this to governments this always
goes to humanitarian partner
organizations this is the principle
that underlies humanitarian aid that the
european union provides
to those in need now with this three and
a half million
purely humanitarian aid will reach 13.8
million
since the um since the beginning of 2018
so we've provided nearly
14 million euro in humanitarian
assistance to
bosnia in order to enable the country to
better manage migration related issues
now in terms of what um the three and a
half million euro
will be used for i can mention a couple
of uh examples for you
which include the um
buying warm clothing blankets food as
well as health care
or provision of mental health and
psychosocial
support services and of course the
funding that we provide will also
contribute to efforts
to limit the spread of the kernel virus
now in terms of the
other components of the overall figure
of of 88 million euro that peter
referred to
i think peter anna can provide you more
information
peter can you provide more information
on this
yes i mean we are happy to do it also
bilaterally it has been published as a
part of the press releases issued over
the last few days so
i think we can send this information but
the bottom line i would really like to
repeat the message the eu has done its
part
migration is a shared challenge we
provided a lot of
financial assistance both through the
partners through our projects to the
bosnia herzegovina authorities to deal
with the situation
and there are facilities on the spot so
it's unacceptable that these people are
left
hanging out there in harsh winter
conditions and the situation needs to be
solved
as a matter of urgency nikolai short
follow-up
yes thank you for that i just wanted to
know when
these supplies will be delivered to
these people
um is it is it is it happening now or
when when when will they get it thank
you yes so in terms of humanitarian
assistance the way it works is that we
provide the funds to
humanitarian partner organizations
typically this means ngos or
possibly uin organizations which are
then um
to buy or purchase what needs to be but
what needs to be purchased
now on our end we made the announcement
yesterday and
we will disburse these funds as soon as
possible i will look into this study in
the afternoon and i will try to give you
a
specific timeline on this
thank you okay i see one last
hand raised james wilson james
yes good afternoon my question relates
to
brexit and the erasmus program
uh as most people will know the uk
decided to opt out of the
erasmus program however since then
the republic of ireland uh very
generously
extended financial provision to enable
northern ireland universities to take
part
my question relates to scottish
universities
which for many years have extended
education free of tuition fees
to students coming from the eu
and my question is this would would the
european commission
look favorably upon an application
from scottish universities to remain
in the erasmus program provided that
they
paid their own financial share
contributing towards the program
thank you that would be a question um
well i'm not quite sure who now let's
see if dan
has anything to say on the um on the
issue
hi eric and hi james thanks very much
for your question and a happy new year
um i mean i would just reiterate what
you yourself said the uk government
decided that it no longer wanted to take
part in erasmus which is something that
um we regret of course we have seen the
the news in the press announced by the
by the irish government this is
something we take note of
um it's worth recalling as well that
the withdrawal agreement covers students
currently on erasmus and
for the current um for the 2014 2020 mmf
but of course the going forward the uk
will no longer be part of this
as for your question on scotland um this
is a hypothetical question
and i wouldn't have anything to say in
it
thank you very much okay we'll take two
last questions today
anna you have the floor
hello hello and happy new year i have a
question about
gibraltar following the preliminary deal
between madrid and london
i would like to know which are going to
be the next steps
if there is already a calendar for
fixing the treaty
and i would like also to understand a
little bit more about
the role that is reserved uh for front
text
and when they could start working
on gibraltar thank you done
hi anna can you hear me yes go ahead
yes hello ayanna thanks very much for
your question uh
indeed we are now examining um
the the agreement reached in principle
between spain and
the united kingdom on new year's eve
regarding gibraltar i don't have a
specific timeline to provide you with
uh right now but we are uh we are
working on this
and um working on this within the view
of going towards the council to get a
mandate
to begin formal negotiations
thank you last question goes to oliver
yes i think you should hear me now it
says live on this we do
yes yes uh fantastic um
[Music]
what is your reaction to the europe
server story
uh the publication of a recording of i
think the former
kgb boss belarusian belarusian
kgb boss where he talks about
assassinating belarusian opposition
politicians in germany
does that change your outlook on on the
policy
towards the lukashenko regime thank you
thank you peter no we have no comments
to make on on
on this issue and our policy vis-a-vis
belarus is very very well known we will
not comment on on
this report
thank you very much this brings our
first midday briefing of the year to a
close
and we will meet again here in the press
room tomorrow
at 12. thank you